Claire Crawley fetch Lorette how do you
feel about the choice it was out of left
field we're so thrilled like we could
not be more thrilled I keep saying this
but it's like my husband asked the woman
on a date and kissed her and yet I think
she is so awesome still so that's how
great of a Bachelorette she's gonna be
it was five years ago so yes I had a
moment last night so last night we had a
watch party at Amy Sherman's house and
she brought a cake for Ashley because it
was her birthday last week and so here I
am I was filming Ashley and in the TV in
the background was Claire and I had a
moment to myself I was like if you had
asked me five years ago that Here I am
Here I am I'd be sitting five years
later married to Ashley I can Eddie
while on the TV in the background Claire
Crawley was just announced as the
Bachelorette be like what the hell is
going on let's just say that Claire's
the perfect combination of nurturing and
warm and kick-ass hurry you know she's
not gonna take any crap from guys I'm
hoping the guys came out today I heard
that there's a lot of younger guys like
in their 20s only nine over the age of
30 so I'm hoping those nine are the
final behind good boys
I mean I think we were all hoping maybe
there would be not that a woman can't
date a younger man but maybe a little
more of a mix but we shall see guys we
needed a drink after last night didn't
we Oh girls I just finished all my
recaps before I got here and now I'm
like yes I won't have that one thank you
I saw that you give a little love to
your own mother-in-law on the gram mom
and Nance would never it seems how do
you guys feel though about the barb of
it all it's just sad she was so mean I
feel so bad I feel bad for Peter I feel
going from Madison it's amazing I
thought last night she was gonna go in
there and be like okay I support my son
I love my son and that's not what
happened she said on TV that Madison and
Peter will not make it the part that
really got to me was when she said
Hannah and compromised
and Madison wouldn't compromise and I
was like yeah she wouldn't compromise
her values she gave your son a choice it
was a lot to take in I agree I thought
barb was gonna come in a little more
middle ground but she really drew a line
well what I thought was really
interesting was that she got so much fan
hate on Monday that I thought that she
would use the live show to recover but
she really just could not help herself
barb leaned right in yeah well let me
ask you guys Peter himself said Madison
and I have only uphill battles from here
what advice would you give to them if
they do try to make this work and what
do you think they have facing them
because I know it's already hard enough
to make a relationship work after the
show god I don't know I mean there is a
part of me
I remember when Madison was telling
Peter that they weren't compatible as I
was watching it I thought yeah she's
right like she was bringing up such good
points so I do think they have a uphill
battle my big advice for beat for Peter
Madison would try to block out the noise
as best as possible ignore everything
that everybody is saying try to work on
each other even get off social media for
a little while because it's just in pot
if you're on Instagram it's impossible
not to read comments and then you know
those comments will affect you and make
you mad or angry or sad so try to just
block everything out focus on each other
for a little while like at least a
couple months I'd say I feel like my
advice is simple and it's to Madison and
I think it's a keeper distance from the
whole Webber family how could she date
him and do that I don't think she should
date him is what I'm saying like you
know Peters included in the Webber
family yes
yes it's so crazy though because like
family is the one aspect of this show
that you don't want bad press about
right anytime there's hometowns parents
siblings so one time where everybody
gets a little bit more reserved because
their back is up and they just want to
protect their family because they didn't
sign up for the show but then barb last
night just I it was it she's brought it
so much upon herself almost to a point
where was it done on purpose
there was actually Nick tweeted this and
it's not the worst theory nakiya
it's nothing worse there I've heard
which was maybe barb tried to take the
heat off her son by bringing the heat on
herself so everybody today we'd be
talking about her instead of Peter and
she would have succeeded very much so
I'm calling it the barb chiller now it's
a different show Madison good job for
walking away cuz she straight up said we
have way too many differences now you're
somebody who and I know you've talked
about this you came on the show as a
virgin yourself what do you feel like
about how things ended up for her I mean
disappointing but it did seem like with
Peter he was willing as he told his
brother to stayin forgo that part of
their relationship until they were
married so I don't really think it was
her virginity that got in the way I
think it was her not asked not um I
think was him not you know listening to
her request you guys are still so tapped
into the bachelor world you hang out
with people from the world what is the
behind-the-scenes talk like are people
who are alumni of this show saying I
can't believe that happened
well what happened barb yeah and the
ending I think there's two mind-boggling
things about last night it was the fact
that barb didn't control herself and it
was that Peter proposed to Hannah and
just a day after he was telling his
family he was telling Chris Harrison
that he wasn't sure he could continue
because his heart was at Madison sounds
like you think Peter screwed up yeah I
mean I think everybody thinks that way I
mean he proposed a Hannah and broke it
off
and then so I don't know I don't know if
he liked it seems that he doesn't want
to be with Hannah and then it seemed
like he didn't want to be with Madison
and Madison they're both so it feels
uneasy about the future of the
relationship so it does feel like what
did we just watch why it was Peter
thinking what was Peter thinking I I
don't understand what he was thinking he
knew he wasn't gonna look good and he
also knew he wasn't going to be
fulfilled by proposing to Hannah and
after he was so open about his feelings
about Madison I think I think Peter
suffers a little bit from nice guy
syndrome because he does seem like a
really nice guy but he also seems like a
guy who tries to please everybody and
worries about what everybody thinks and
so I'm sure in that moment when Madison
left he was like well I could see a
future with him and so I'll propose and
it's like no you can't propose to
someone that you might see a future with
like you have when you propose to
someone like I did yes you know you you
plan to spend the rest of your life with
them and that's kind of a commitment
that you make to them and so it's just
it's a mess so as much of a reality show
as it is you got to take it seriously
[Music]